my name is Bob fine I've worked on Wall
Street for nearly 30 years I'm going to
talk about my experience leveraging the
Wolfram ecosystem to develop a number of
tools which automate the process of
operating over large data sets
and Bob fine pleasure to be here
I was fat for the longest time I was
speaking tomorrow at 8:30 and I realized
a few days ago I'm the first one so he
said nobody's left the conference yet so
I'm going to talk about my experiences
on Wall Street specifically the way we
term it is using Mathematica and the
Wolfram language is the scripting
language in order to create some
automation tools that operate over large
datasets and specifically in my case
Bloomberg datasets so I'm going to cover
I'll cover a little bit about my
background they'll talk about the
project I'll talk about some general
thoughts about well from doing business
on Wall Street so I've I've been in the
municipal finance industry on Wall
Street for about 30 years the municipal
in municipal finance is is it's our own
little kind of world on Wall Street
which is part of the fixed income world
everything is tax-exempt bonds and the
clients are municipal issuers so that
includes mostly generous cities towns
municipalities and then some other
entities like hospitals and the
airport's it's I I worked over the years
for Prudential base Goldman Sachs JP
Morgan a bondage or in start-up which
was a very interesting experience I was
not your kind of I wasn't the guy going
out and doing the glad handling and
during the shaking hands I was I was
more of a quantitative guy and in the
municipal finance world that means the
only with cash flow structured cash
flows and and and and and being able to
structure them and being able to
calculate very
cause various returns cost the capital
essentially I are ours for most of my
career I did this in Excel I was very
good I was probably one of the top five
people in the municipal finance industry
in terms of quantitative structuring
abilities in Excel it was kind of well
known across the the industry but Excel
is very kind of constraining and
frustrating there's you may be aware and
so I was introduced to Mathematica by a
guy who became a close friend and a
mentor about ten you know nor ten years
ago at the bond insurance startup this
guy was a brilliant guy he was chief
technology officer at Citigroup right
now is chief technology officer one of
the main business lines of Bank in New
York and he said for what we need to do
with the intellectual property and I at
the bond insurance company and I was
kind of shepherding the intellectual
property you may need Mathematica I was
do not have a computer science
background and but I know in my head
kind of all this all the stuff with that
needed to be done with the operating
over the cash flows and he said
Mathematica is the way we're gonna go
and he was there he helped me and so
here I am today
so in municipal finance this is kind of
framing the problem it's driven by a
marketing cycle which means that the
bankers are going out and touching
clients making presentation to clients
kind of at least you know two or three
times a year and in order to do that
they need pitch books in order to do
that they need to have a comprehensive
very detailed very accurate
understanding the finest outstanding
debt and then the main kind of selling
point
and the client mainly have new money
needs which means they have to issue
issue debt for new projects are the
other big source of revenue in municipal
finance departments up through the end
of the year when Congress amended the
law was as called advanced refunding is
essentially your refunding debt the
issue is getting savings and the broker
dear or the underwriter is getting a fat
a fat fee for issuing new bonds and the
the current state and the state for the
last 30 years has been all this work
gets done by lots of warm bodies young
kids prying data at a primary disclosure
documents working kind of you know like
seamstresses in Excel spreadsheets
maintaining so Excel spreadsheets and a
very diverse unsecured you know windows
file system and these guys these kids
were in heaven ii want to change so i
have i have to turn my cyborg ratio you
know machine the cyborgs have to have
part man half machine so when that in
the current environment more or less
it's kind of that the manual labor is 90
percent and she labors at 10 percent so
my objective was taking my Mathematica
skills because after after the bond
insurance experience they I came back to
to a couple of as smaller investment
banks doing really finding us and I
convinced them that you know I should
write this code that'll kind of automate
some of the workflows and and so the
idea was to have some sort of
application that would take data and all
the data that they were getting out of
kind of hard copies are maintaining and
Excel spreadsheets was in Bloomberg so
you can you know so the the data source
was Bloomberg the goal was to pull that
in have and and have code operator
operate over it do all the
and then create schedules client ready
schedules so that literally I would just
I would just hit the button and this
thing wouldn't kind of run in there you
know in a couple of seconds sometimes
depending on the size of the data set it
would take it could take you know five
or ten minutes or even longer but once
the button was pressed I just sat back
and and let the thing run all right you
know that was my goal and just to
reiterate I've got this comment at the
bottom of the slide it's very difficult
that Mykel workflow automation enter
certain and into certain wall street
environments particularly wall street
environments where compensations driven
by revenue production as opposed to
managing the PML so me me finance its it
compensations revenue production so I
was alone I had no other resources
allocated to me so based on that and
based on my knowledge of of Wolfram I
said okay I'm just going to do I'm going
to use Wolfram to get me from beginning
to end again even so far is pulling the
Bloomberg data using Bloomberg link as
opposed to the Bloomberg Excel API both
are doable but the Bloomberg linkers is
very fast and very efficient again so
the bliss of Bloomberg source use
Wolfram functions as operators and then
the final output that I designed was
generated using report template
functionality which I don't know if
you've had any experience without it
it's very interesting and in certain
respects very powerful and again what
you know what one 1-click runs all and
then the end and you use a ready data
output as PDFs and HTML so this thing if
you want it could go right to clients so
let me kind of dig in a little bit and
kind of show you kind of the some
components and and and the workflow so
this is a
a small sample of the Bloomberg data
sets that I was operating over and again
this is not just a this data for
presentation purposes it's coming from
the Excel API but you can see that there
are yeah and the columns go go to the
further to right there about 40 fields
and again the rows I mean it's
completely scalable the one thing to
notice is in the third what the fourth
column series ID that's critical because
in in municipal finance you've got
syriza bonds and a series of bonds is
made up of individual maturities twenty
or thirty individual maturities so I was
working over individual maturities and
series of bonds so that and this is
provided by Bloomberg that series
identifiers there's what allowed me to
kind of do the groupings I needed you
know to do the calculations so here's a
sample output number one and apologize
this is a cut and paste from a doe from
Adobe into PowerPoint and you obviously
don't need to see that individual
numbers or the detail to kind of get a
sense first of all of how this is laid
out that it's very kind of very neat and
and then kind of publish it's published
like it's it's grouped the the report
template does all the groupings and this
a report like this could go 70 pages
with the with the you know blocking out
the issuers and this particular one is
it shows an issue of Hamilton County is
an issue or and then these are the
series under that issuer and then within
each of the series there are individual
bonds and again this this sample you're
looking at is just Bloomberg data
rearranged and formatted on the page now
this output takes
the Bloomberg data we just saw and
analyzes the the string descriptions of
what the purpose of each of the series
and from a tax perspective and and the
the goal is to kind of look at pick out
the Series in the bonds that are valence
refundable refundable and and and what's
refundable is is governed by a very
complicated set of IRS rules so though
you can impute what advanced what bonds
are refundable by looking at the
bloomberg descriptions and so I used the
piecewise function and a set of
parameters to to look at the
descriptions and then if if admit if if
if a bond they're series met the
requirements to be refunded but one
would go into the first bucket and there
were other kind of buckets as well they
were important so this now is an
analysis so it's so the program had
sorted through or filtered out all of
the bonds that had were that that the
algorithm previously had determined were
refundable and so on a bond by bond
basis a row by row basis that the the
code operates over each each of the
bonds to determine a savings amount for
each of the bonds based on kind on input
which is a reflects current market
condition there's a lot of use of
financial bond again it really has to do
with pricing pricing the bonds at
various rates and looking at the
difference but again sample up for three
is all analysis and then sample output
for takes is a little different in that
it takes the results of three within us
an issuer and it combines them all and
and looks at cash flows representing a
fat pad and where all of those bonds
would be refunded kind of at once
there's a single portfolio so again this
is stuff that issuers the bankers look
at day in and day out it's just bread
and butter stuff on the one hand it was
kind of being done by hand and here it's
just done with one click of the button
this is my my wrapper function this is
the one function that's it's a big that
what I you know I had visions for kind
of moving this forward in terms of a UI
or being able for other people to use it
but at this current point it's this is a
function it sits in a notebook there are
these variables are assigned values at
the top of the notebook there's an
initialization function where I call all
I got about eight packages running
having code in it the rule that this
function relies on and I call I
initialize those and then I run this and
so what's happening here is that the
first few variables like Bank or issue
if you were named all all the inputs are
out and the outputs are sitting in a
very kind of rudimentary windows window
server file system so these these
variables will populate path names that
I've got in the code so it'll know where
to go and grab the the input and and
push the output you there are some
inputs some variables that that control
did that have to do with with with dates
and control the the market skid the
market information that needs to be
pulled in and then set a start date for
the in for the analysis and then some
other switches
which allow me to control exactly what
reports I'm printing out whether or not
I'm going to pull in a data a bloomberg
data set that comes from Bloomberg
Mathematica Bloomberg link or an excel
file and things like that which you know
depending on you know what I was doing
and when having control over this
certainly controlled ha you know the the
time it took to do an analysis so if I
didn't need to do a full-blown analysis
that someone was already done I could
cut down the the processing time by by
turning off some some reports to get a
little bit in the weeds way I dealt with
with the Bloomberg data as structured
data sets the own you know it allows you
to do the group by join across very
efficient mapping structures so if you
do a group by on my series then you can
that creates sub matrices sub matrices
and those can be mapped individually
those elements can individually be
mapped to two functions and then report
templates and and again check you know
you set up your template in advance and
then you just you know give it the
temple to generate document as the key
driving function you give it a template
name you've created the Association
based on based on the matrices that were
created by the by the the functionality
operating over the bloom board Davis's
piecewise was an important function I
used financial bond and then if you look
at kind of that the structure of a
municipal bond series it's it's very
much well it is a system of linear
equations so in excel you essentially
are solving from from the back end your
bootstrapping from the back end here
using linear solve a linear
you know setting setting the problem up
taking the data and then and then
setting up abstract matrices that then
ran through linear solve linear
programming was just a very efficient
way to to deal with this so I'm down to
about six or seven minutes marketing w/e
though the Wolfram ecosystem on Wall
Street I put this slide together over
the weekend and then listening to Steven
last night kind of cake you know came
away kind of thinking somewhat diplom I
mean from listening to Steven last night
the competition worth caring about is
neither MATLAB or Python the issue I
think and I was kind of overheard this
and some conversations last night and
this morning the issue is that there's
been you know mathematic is a the
Wolfram ecosystem is just a great system
but it's been there's no awareness of it
I'm Wall Street I would have to explain
to people what I you know when it was
explaining what I was doing interesting
well I'm I'm using I'm using Mathematica
I'm using the Wolfram language have you
heard of it no well its first I was
saying well it's like MATLAB and they've
heard of MATLAB and now at least I can
say after this experience and and seeing
how close how similar this process I did
would be to writing the same code in
Python I can say yeah it's a it's like
Python but it's kind of more efficient
it's faster to develop you know you
don't have to go kind of all over the
internet you know looking for libraries
it's all all contained and and and and
that's the big issue that's the big
issue
I'd say you know if if it's not up to me
to tell you know Stephen what is you
know what his goals and objectives are
but I would say if you know if you want
to get the two thousand please as
opposed to Karen eight yeah you know the
has to be more efficient and kind of
picking a spot either picking a spots or
just getting the word out and you know
Wall Street companies though will pay a
premium all day long for value I don't
think any of us in the room doubts the
value that it's in Mathematica and and
the Wolfram ecosystem so take questions
yeah well I I don't think that's the
question I think well yeah just one way
to answer that is I would like more
people to know it and you know so that
I'm not you know the only one doing
you've got to have more users out there
more people didn't understand that
they're trained in it that you know so
if I do this and leave a company there
are other people that can take it over
and that was pretty like you know yeah
you know if somebody were kind of you
know thinking careful about this they
may have said no Bob you know if you
leave who's gonna who's gonna kind of
run this but you know they didn't say
that but that's that's that's an issue
to make my life easier
I mean to you know again it's it's
marketing branding kind of having a very
kind of easy to grasp message and just
and just getting the word out more
effectively so people know what it is
I'm not no well I'm you know I never
used I never used Excel link it doesn't
work the latest I don't know if we
changed within the last ten months but
it doesn't Excel link doesn't work in
64-bit Excel and just you know I mean
you've still got to kind of be able to
write your functionality in in
Mathematica no no no no no I mean I was
writing I was I was exporting the the
output of generated generate documents
as PDFs and HTML so wait so if you
wanted to work in Excel you just would
you know you can copy and paste the HTML
in Excel and there were also some some
tables that I I exported unformatted
directly directly to an XLS file so I
yeah I don't see that excel link and you
know what again I never really got my
head around it I always knew what was
out there and I always kind of said well
I'm gonna I'm gonna focus on it but I
never did
yeah I think I would argue that I mean
there is I think most of the jargon is
Muni finance jargon
well I mean yeah yeah
right I mean the issuer name is coming
directly from from Bloomberg right yeah
right but everything else is is Muni
finance peak so yeah I don't think
that's an issue for you know once you
were in that world
yeah right yeah well a lot right and it
was never kind of thought of that way
III mean again what I did is very
rudimentary you really need a database
to kind of you know store the Bloomberg
data and then they're a legal issues
there but and then push it back out and
then take the results and push it back
into a database and I really ought to go
to a report writer right
and it really ought to be sitting in the
cloud and be accessible from within the
firm you know be a URL got a more
web-based and then the other thing that
I started working on is using it because
I had an enterprise version of funniest
platform which comes with the Bloomberg
link and it also comes with the
enterprise CDF I don't know if you've
had experience with enterprise CVS but
they're really the way to kind of
package what I've done as an application
that other people in the organization
can use so it would open up
the enterprise CDF allows you to take
external data in other words allows you
to reach out to the file system to to
the Bloomberg data and pull it in pull
different versions of the Bloomberg data
and the issue there is it just becomes
very kind of cumbersome to write to
write a really neat kind of clean
front-end the people kind of a
comfortable sitting and then using they
never quite quite got that I'm done all
right thank you